>> Greg: THE PATHETIC BUBBLE
THE INDUSTRY LIVES IN.
ONE SHOWRUNNER SAID AFTER TRUMP,
WE DESERVE TO HAVE SOME
FRIVOLITY.
AS IF THEY DIDN’T HAVE ENOUGH.
THAT’S LIKE CHRIS CUOMO SAYING
HE NEEDS A BIGGER EGO.
WRITING ANTI-TRUMP YUKS IS AS
BIG AS FIRES FOR TERRORISTS.
WHAT SMALL PEOPLE WITH HUGE
BLIND SPOTS.
BEFORE COVID CAN WE HAVE THE
STRONGEST ECONOMY IN MODERN
HISTORY.
AFTER COVID WE ARE COMING BACK.
PEACE BREAKING OUT OVER WHICH
LEFT OTHERS LIKE COLBERT AND
OTHERS WHICH THEY
THE TRAUMA THEYEXPERIENCE FROM A
WHO CARES IF YOUNG ADULTS DIDN’T
DIE IN COMBAT OR HOUSEHOLD
INCOME ROSE BY THE HUNDREDS OR
EVERYBODY HAS GOT A JOB, TRUMP
KEPT NOAH AWAKE ALL NIGHT.
POST TRUMP, SHE’S LOOKING
FORWARD TO A DIVERSITY OF
THOUGHT WHICH MEANS TWO
THOUGHTS, I HATE TRUMP AND I
REALLY MISS HATING TRUMP.
THERE WEREN’T OTHER THINGS TO
LAUGH AT?
>> WHY AREN’T BY 50 POINTS
AHEAD, YOU MIGHT ASK.
>> WHAT DO THE FACTS SAY?
>> THE FACTS SUGGEST THAT YOU
ABSOLUTELY DON’T HAVE
NATIVE AMERICAN
>> SOMETHING YOU COULD GET.
CHOCOLATE, SOME OTHER CHOCOLATE
HERE.
>> KEEPS TURNING UP AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
>> KONSTANTIN KILIMNIK.
>> THIS WAS THE ACTUAL SWAB
BEING USED.
>> Greg: NO HUMOR TO BE FOUND
HERE.
MY PRODUCER PUT THAT TOGETHER IN
MINUTES.
WHAT FOUR TEAMS OF LATE-NIGHT
PRODUCERS COULDN’T DO IN FOUR
YEARS BUT I GUESS THOSE TARGETED
HIT CLOSE TO HOME AND THEIR
POCKETS.
THEY NEED FRIVOLITY NOT BECAUSE
THEY EXPERIENCE ANY HARM TRUMP
DID TO THE COUNTRY, TRUMP PUT AN
OWWIE ON THEIR PSYCHES.
I’M EXCITED PRESIDENT OBAMA IS
GOING TO BE ON JIMMY KIMMEL THIS
WEEK.
I WONDER WHO’S GOING TO GET THE
ROWS.
SPEED TO BARACK OBAMA BOOK
>> Dana: BARACK OBAMA BOOK
DIDN’T CREATE ANY BUZZ.
APPARENTLY THE FAR LEFT IS
REALLY DISAPPOINTED.
THE CHARACTERIZATION OF BIDEN --
THEY SAY IT’S NOT FUNNY.
THEY SAY IT’S HERO WORSHIP AND
THEY ARE BORED BY IT.
>> Greg: JESSE, I LIKE HOW
THEY PRETEND THERE IS NOTHING
ELSE TO POKE FUN OF.
>> Jesse: TRUMP WAS PRETTY
FUNNY, GREG.
HE TRIED TO BUY GREENLAND, HE
BOUGHT THE CLEMSON FOOTBALL TEAM
$5,000 WORTH OF FAST FOOD BUT HE
MET WITH KIM JONG UN TWICE.
THE GUY WAS A CONTENT MACHINE
BUT HE BROUGHT A WHOLE CAST OF
CHARACTERS.
REMEMBER THE MOOCH?
KELLY AND, SARAH SANDERS COMING
IN, MELANIA.
WHO IS BIDEN COMING IN?
HUNTER?
YOU CAN MAKE FUNNY JOKES ABOUT
KEMAL HARRIS TELL MY CONNIVING
IN THE BACKGROUND.
IT’S NOT THAT FUNNY.
I THINK TRUMP MADE LATE-NIGHT
COMEDY GREAT AGAIN BUT "THE
FIVE" STILL BEATS ALL THOSE GUYS
IN THE RATINGS.
WE DON’T EVEN HAVE WRITERS!
IMAGINE HOW FUNNY I WOULD BE IF
WE HAD A WRITER!
I’D HAVE TO LOOK INTO THAT.
>> Greg: JUAN, THEY ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO DIVERSITY.
AREN’T THEY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
LACK OF DIVERSITY IN THE FIRST
PLACE?
>> Juan: I THINK YOU ARE, CLEARL
MAKING FUN OF TRUMP, THERE ISN’T
MUCH DIVERSITY IN TRUMP’S WORLD.
BIDEN AT LEAST TO ME COMES
ACROSS AS A NORMAL GUY.
ON THE AMTRAK TRAIN IN THE
NIGHT, A GUY YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT BIG POLITICIANS --
>> Jesse: THAT WAS 20 YEARS
AGO.
>> Dana: I RODE THE AMTRAK
WITH THEM IN YEARS.
HE WAS SHOCKED.
WANTED TO GET AWAY FROM ME AS
FAST AS HE COULD.
>> Juan: BIG TIME POLITICIANS
USE THEIR INFLUENCE, HIS SON
WENT TO WAR.
HE SUFFERED LOSSES IN HIS LIFE.
THE PROBLEM IS HE’S BORING, HE’S
NORMAL, HE’S A NORMAL GUY.
FOR A COMEDIAN, NORMAL IS NOT
FUNNY.
WHAT JESSE LAID OUT IS A LOT OF
STUFF YOU COULD MAKE FUN OF EVEN
IF YOU WERE A TRUMP MAN.
>> Greg: THAT’S THE PROBLEM.
JOE BIDEN IS SO NORMAL THAT YOU
COULDN’T POSSIBLY MAKE FUN OF
HIM.
THERE IS NOTHING THERE, KENNEDY,
TO MAKE FUN OF!
>> Kennedy: DO YOU KNOW WHAT
THE FUNNIEST PRESIDENTIAL
IMPRESSION OTHER THAN DARRELL
HAMMOND DOING CLINTON?
CHEVY CHASE DOING GERALD FORD
BECAUSE HE DIDN’T TRY TO LOOK
LIKE HIM, DIDN’T TRY TO SOUND
LIKE HIM.
HE JUST MADE HIM SEEM KIND OF
DUMB BECAUSE HE WAS VERY
ORDINARY AVERAGE PRESIDENT AND
THAT’S WHAT MADE IT SO
HYSTERICAL.
THE THING THAT OFFENDS ME MOST
ABOUT THE LATE-NIGHT WRITING
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS IT’S
IT’S BEEN SO UNIMAGINATIVE AND
IT’S BEEN THE SAME JOKE
REWRITTEN AND DELIVERED WITH THE
SAME CONTEMPT AND IN THE SAME
WAY AND THERE HAVE BEEN NO
BOUNDARIES THAT HAVE BEEN PUSHED
HERE AND THAT’S WHY FOR A LOT OF
THESE SHOWS, PEOPLE HAVE MOVED
ON TO OTHER CONTENT.
PEOPLE ARE MORE EXCITED ABOUT
WHAT THEY CAN BINGE WATCH ON
NETFLIX THEN THEY ARE ABOUT WHAT
COLBERT SAID LAST NIGHT BECAUSE
MOST PEOPLE JUST DON’T CARE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE RENDERED
THEMSELVES IRRELEVANT BY THIS
REDUNDANCY IN THEIR HUMOR.
I THINK IT’S GOING TO BE VERY
BAD NEWS FOR ORGANIZATIONS, NOT
JUST LATE-NIGHT, BUT
"NEW YORK TIMES," MSNBC, AND
OTHER PLACES THAT HAVE SEEN
THEIR RATINGS AND SUBSCRIBER
SHIP QUADRUPLE DURING THE TRUMP
ERA COULD IMPLODE.
WHAT IS THE ANSWER GOING TO LOOK
LIKE THIS THE LAST FEW YEARS?
>> Greg: IT’S STILL FUN THAN
BEN STILLER.
WOULD YOU AGREE?
>> Dana: I STILL WANT TO SEE
BEN STILLER.
>> Greg: IS HE STILL IN THE
END OF HIM AND INDUSTRY?
>> Dana: I DON’T KNOW.